right happy saturday about to go work
out but i
thought about y'all and said let me ask
you all a question
is there anybody who is preventing you
from being you from living your true
self
is it if the answer to that is
anybody other than you then baby you
living for approval
from other people you got to live for
you
until you do that then you ain't free
okay your life
is your business okay hello there that
was tabatha brown known as
america's mom for satisfying the hunger
of millions on tick tock and instagram
i love her so much she started doing
cooking shows and product reviews back
in 2017
and her viral her videos quickly went
viral
then two weeks later she jumped onto
tiktok to share her vegan inspired meals
now the social media star has over 10
million followers
tabitha is not letting her huge platform
go to waste
during the pandemic she started giving
motivational talks while teaching her
fans
how to make delicious vegan dishes so
she's literally feeding
our souls while going about her business
of course
and she just received an naacp image
award nomination
for outstanding social media personality
actress and vegan foodie tabitha brown
joins me now i'm so excited to have
you on the show how are you doing today
i am well hello there how are you i'm
excited to be here i appreciate it
i'm so i i'm you know it's friday i'm
feeling
grateful and tabitha it feels to me like
the world needed someone like you in it
right
we needed you know i i think of you as
like human
sunshine like you're bright and you're
inspiring
and in this dark year that we've had
you're like the bright
light that we're all looking towards
what inspired you to use your platform
to help people
just get through this it's hard
well first of all thank you for saying
that i appreciate that you know
when the shutdown happened everywhere
you turned all you saw was cobra 19
corona vibes all these different things
uh and it was very dark and i decided i
wanted to be
everything but that i wanted to try to
be
joy and light and i wanted to be a place
where people could go
uh to kind of take their mind off of the
evident that we all know is happening
right even if it's for one minute i want
to give a little joy a little laughter
some good food
okay uh and that's why i started doing
it and when i started seeing the
comments
it really became a responsibility and i
took it serious and i said you know what
i'm gonna show up every day for these
people
and i want them to feel like i'm their
family i'm their friend in this moment
and that's why i did it
one of the things i love that you say is
like you go ahead
and enjoy your day but even if you're
not having a good day
don't go messing up anybody else's day
and i think that's so
smart because i feel like you know
oftentimes
you know what we have our bad days in
the pandemic you take it one day at a
time
basically one hour at a time but why do
you think it's so important that
i mean if you're having a bad day don't
try to make anybody else's day bad
also try to you know work through it and
stay optimistic and positive in your own
in your own self in your own mind
oh absolutely what you know that's how
my daddy raised me right he would always
tell me listen just because you're
having a bad day don't mean you got to
go mess up somebody else's
energy is a real thing it's just like i
could be
you know full of joy and sunshine and
happiness and i can walk into the room
and people can feel that
but if you're having a bad day you can
also walk into the room heavy and
sad or mad and angry and people feel
that
energy transfers and you can affect
someone else that way
and so just because your day is bad you
don't have to intentionally go and mess
somebody else's up
that's just you know it's a way of life
and it's how we should gossip
i love that the new york times today
published an article about how optimism
can be a tool to help people through
tough times
do you agree i mean how what keeps you
positive how do you stay
optimistic if you're having a bad moment
because i know that the moment will pass
right
i choose to always focus on it being
temporary
yeah some days we're gonna have a rough
day some days things just not gonna go
right
but we know it's temporary and it will
pass
and i've suffered you know in depression
and anxiety and it's not fun
you know being in a dark space is not
fun and so i just always promised myself
if i come out of that
i'm going to be a source of light and
i'm going to try my best to always focus
on the positive
and that's what i choose to do it's a
choice it's a hard choice for some
people
but it's still a choice
oh yeah i feel that too it's like i
could choose to focus on the negative
but
that's no fun who wants to stay there um
so everybody listening um they know
this this about me i can't cook i like
it's it's embarrassing
my mom she tried really hard she taught
me things
and i forgot all of them all every
single thing
and when i try to cook now i'm just very
upset because
i was like i know i had this skill in my
brain and it's gone
um what's the simplest maybe vegan dish
that i could try that
won't be embarrassing well
first and foremost if it was there
before it's still there
okay you just got to get in there and
play all right don't take it so serious
i believe in you that you can do that
uh but you know what's so easy is tacos
tacos are always easy because you got to
have whatever your feeling
is so if you want to do a veggie taco
you can just saute veggies
and that's simple it's putting a little
garlic powder you know
taco seasoning on them and then you got
your tortillas and you just fill them up
or you can use a vegan substitute of you
know meat substitute
you ground it you know or you know brown
it just like you would
regular ground turkey or bee and saute
it until it's brown
season it and then put it in your shell
and top it with your favorites like your
lettuce tomato pico de gallo or avocado
or guacamole
and uh it's simple right and it looked
fancy it looked like you did something
yeah yeah you can i believe it's all an
illusion
i'm going to try tacos i think i can
handle tacos i can do this
and i'm not going to post it on social
media but i may i may post a photo
and send it to you just to prove that i
followed through on on your suggestion
um so as a okay good so as a black girl
who rocks her natural hair
okay good so as a black girl who rocks
her natural hair
i i really love this video in particular
so i want to take a look at it
and we'll chat about it on the other
side
people be like oh your hair's so pretty
is it real can i touch it
yes it's real no you can't touch it is
you my husband
and her name is donna put some respect
on her name okay
[Music]
why did you feel it's important to just
just directly address
all of the comments that i'm sure that
you get from all kinds of people about
your hair
well you know that little challenge was
going around and i thought oh this would
be a fun opportunity to make it
short and sweet you know i get that so
often uh and before you know
code it happened people would randomly
just come up to me and
tug on my hair and oh is it real or you
know oh can i touch it or
and i just thought it's so weird that
you just want to
walk up to me and touch my first of all
be in my personal space and just touch
and grab my hair and asking someone is
it real
it's a part of me absolutely you know
and i just thought
well here's a way to say it have a
little fun with
it but get my point across and you know
my hair has
a whole personality all on her own this
is donna and she got a whole life
and so uh i just thought you know what
i'm gonna do it this way
how do you how do you keep your your
curls popping because they're
always popping well it depends
right so when it's like this this is a
you know the curly look after i have
washed and
moisturized and i haven't picked her out
all the way but i you know i use a
little product you know i also have my
donna's recipe
which is my own product line for
strength and you know hair growth
and when i just really want her to be
free i just pick her out and let her do
what she gonna do
my big afro is like my favorite right
and what i'm
you know most known for but just keeping
it moisturized and making sure you talk
to her on a regular basis so she do
right
i'd be like girl donna honey you in
control girl okay
do right for me
i haven't named my afro you've given me
now
inspiration i'm going to name my afro
and i'm going to start talking to her
i am so into this idea tabitha brown it
has been a joy
thank you so much for being here and for
being the light during this pandemic
please vote for tabitha for the naacp
image award
for outstanding social media personality
and thank you so much for being here
please stay safe have a great weekend
hi i'm zerlina maxwell thanks for
checking out our channel on youtube
you can see more from zerlina by
clicking any of the videos on this
screen
and make sure you subscribe below to
stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories
thanks for watching